the u.n says millions of tons of grain
still need to be cleared from ukrainian
silos to make room for the new harvest
shipments resumed through the black sea
earlier this month after a deal brokered
by turkey lifted a russian blockade the
flow of grain has helped ease food
prices but exports so far are down by
half compared to the same period last
year
dw correspondent matthias bolinga is in
kiev matthias why is it proving so
difficult to get the grain out of
ukraine despite the deal brokered by
turkey
look the deal foresees that ships that
will say will sail into the ukrainian
ports get loaded and then leave the
ports again and uh before the war there
were like something like five ships per
day that's uh that were leaving these
three ports uh plus they are also ports
that are not operating now like the port
of mike live
until now this number which is the
target has not been reached because
there were not enough ships ready to
sail in not enough ships uh we
understand that um that on saturday
ukraine's cabinet approved new measures
to make the process easier what exactly
did they decide
well it's not exactly that they
approved new measures to make the
process easier but there's the hope that
the new measures they introduced will
have an impact basically they introduced
new rules for men men are banned from
leaving the country since the beginning
of the war due to uh potential to be
mobilization so men between 18 and 60
cannot leave ukraine and the government
has approved new rules for uh
men who need to travel on bus for
business purposes and these include uh
sailors so the hope is that if ships
have difficulty finding a crew to sail
in that ukrainian sailors would be more
ready to sail in but the problem is we
also need the ships and there's also the
problem of insurance which is of course
very costly because they're sailing into
a war zone
despite all the guarantees um so it's a
measure that could potentially ease but
it's probably not the solution to the
problem
the complete solution
i suppose not surprisingly the war is
expected to take its toll on ukraine's
grain harvest this year how serious is
the impact likely to be
well look there's about russia is
occupying now something like 20 percent
of ukraine's surface
so this is already territory that will
not uh uh uh
there might be harvests and they might
be taken by russia which is a problem in
itself uh but this will not be grain uh
this grain will not be in in the
ukrainian stocks uh there are battles
there are uh fields burning there have
been accusations that russia was setting
these fields on fire
purposely now this is also not proven
but um of course and their minds so
there are many fields where this year
there won't be any harvest
dw's matthias berlinga in kiev many
thanks matthias
you